من هنا بالضبط
مشيت ربنا نج الحمد
للهد
الحفر هذا المشهد في الصباح فما الذي جرى
هنا في ساعات
[موسيقى]
الليل
الا لا اله الا
الله
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله لا اله الا الله لا اله
الا الله لا اله الا
الله لا اله الا
[موسيقى]
الله تعالي يا عمو تعالي تعالي يا حبيبتي
تعالي تعالي يا عمو تعالي يا حبيبتي تعالي
تعالي يا حبيبتي تعالي تعالي تعالي تعال
حبيبي
تعال تعال تعال تعال خ تعال ضرب يلا يا
حجه تعال تعال
بسرعه خ خلح خل
خلي استنى استنى حب استنى استى استنى يلا
يلا حبيبتي ادخلي ادخلي جوا اجري اجري جوا
جوا جوا
[موسيقى]
خليكي حبيبتي اخل ماما يلا يا عم يلا يا
ماما يا ما يا ماما يلا جوا جوا يا اختي
جوا جوا جوا ياما ه حبيبتي هك
روح يلا ياما يلا يلا يلا هي البنت دخله
جوا حبيبي
يلا احمله
[موسيقى]
تعال يلا انزل اجري اجري اجري يلا
يا جو
[موسيقى]
يلا
ه